it's like a Field of Dreams if you build
it they will come but it's just a dream
that's never gonna become a reality part
of the problem is that Jerry is looking
for something
this ain't no I did this my inclination
is not to spend a thing but on the other
hand I like trains
you may have heard of California's
high-speed rail the 68 billion dollar
project that's supposed to bring the
state's transportation system into the
21st century
California hopes to connect San
Francisco and Los Angeles with America's
first true high-speed rail 520 miles
between them travel time three hours the
project which is the brainchild of
Governor Jerry Brown has gotten plenty
of criticism from both the left and the
right for being a waste of time and
money the real issue in California is
not getting from San Francisco to LA the
the roads work fine it's only when you
get into the area there are lots of
flights so you're really just
essentially replacing Southwest with a
much more expensive slower system that
costs lots of public money Construction
is already over budget and behind
schedule many questioned if the state
has the financial resources to complete
the project despite these hurdles Jerry
Brown and high-speed rail supporters are
moving forward and ramping up efforts to
secure land for the train through the
use of eminent domain the rail
representatives in certain instances are
definitely sort of applying pressure
tactics to the landowners that's ray
Carlson a property lawyer in the Central
Valley that's representing landowners
who claim the high-speed rail is abusing
their property rights through the use of
flash appraisals and other shady
practices some of these appraisals they
didn't even know we're being made they
just ended up on their doorstep one day
ELISA Gomez is one of the people who's
had problems with the land appraisal
process she's a high school teacher in
Corcoran California whose living room is
directly in the path of the Train they
told us to call them when we were ready
for the appraisal or to set up an
appointment probably about a week later
there were appraisers walking up and
down the road and it caught my husband
at lunchtime I wanted to do the
appraisal right then and there
ELISA and her husband rushed home from
work to do the appraisal an email to
follow up questions to the appraiser
never to hear back ELISA then says
officials began contacting her
ex-husband about her property I don't
understand you know why they were
contacting him a little bit of invasion
of privacy
and so open appraisals up multiple
mistakes my name is misspelled spelled
right here misspelled in another area
looked at properties that were less
bedrooms less square footage rundown and
it it was just it was a smack in the
face offer in another part of town Jerry
and mary-jane fagundes are fighting to
keep the home they built over 30 years
ago the train will run 80 feet from
their front door causing severe
vibration and noise but because it
technically doesn't touch their property
line
the rail authority won't even deal with
them we really can't do nothing till
they build the train because they're not
impacting us but talking to a lawyer we
do have to get involved right now with a
letter to state our impacts it's called
inverse condemnation so where they make
our property really worthless without
paying us a dime for it because of the
influence of their project it's just
frustrating it's you know and we've been
the in this since January of 11 and what
have they built what what have they
acquired really I mean by what there's
what is they accomplished if it's still
at a 15% build they still don't have any
more money than they had four years ago
when we started this fight with them
they still don't have answers we still
don't have answers people all up and
down the alignment have gone to public
comment and ask the questions and
they're supposed to answer them some of
a lot of it they say is in their
environmental impact report yes some but
most no so there's still all kinds of
questions out there that are still
floating around four years later and
still haven't been answered the shoddy
way in which the Rail Authority is
conducting some appraisals is not
inspiring much confidence in residents
that the state can get the actual
construction of the 200 mile per hour
train right seems to be herky-jerky I
don't think there's good coordination
within the high-speed rail structure you
ask a point person a question and they
can't give you an answer and they say
they'll they'll give you one later and
then you never hear from them again but
the rail authority has outright
dismissed the fears of property owners
who think they're being taken
for a ride but we're building this and
it's time I think for people to come
together to talk about how we're going
to build it in the most effective way
and and I've just been shocked that a
number of leaders in the Central Valley
continue to want to raise what I think
are spurious specious issues it's clear
that the project has serious flaws with
so many questioning the wisdom of
spending billions on a rail system
instead of funding other urgent state
needs why does the leadership in
Sacramento insist on moving forward
Jerry you know had a problem with his
father's legacy all along his father was
the one who built the modern California
but you know the freeway systems the
aqueducts he was the university system
this the state colleges so really a lot
of it is the legacy of Pat Brown I think
Jerry grew up in opposition to that
legacy and then he's trying to figure
out okay what's my legacy Jerry Brown's
daddy issues could result in the largest
land grab in modern history thousands of
Californians along the alignment are in
danger of losing their property and it
could take years for all the eminent
domain cases to make their way through
court
all this for a project that may never be
completed the timetable keeps getting
pushed back the money issue hasn't gone
away we keep being told that foreign
investors are interested but we've never
told who they are from the point of view
people here it's like it's kind of the
heart of the issue is is this real you
know is it really gonna happen people
will look at this to say well okay do we
pay the pension or do we do this do we
build a water system or do we do this I
mean other words the choices are going
to have to start to be made and while
those choices are being made property
owners will continue to fight for their
rights I think they probably started
here because this is somewhere that is
very simple and yeah maybe they thought
that maybe we were ignorant to you know
what they were doing but that's
definitely not the case there's some
people that that really care about their
property and the people around them and
they do the research and
and they're going to make sure that that
they're held accountable